You're a young kid. I want to hurt you. Sometimes. I really do.
When I look at the videos, you know what I mean? I'm going to go, I, I,
I want to get, but I have to with it. Thank you, man, man. with it.
So when's the Netflix. When is it? It's out. It's out. Yeah, it's out now.
It's a, you guys should go check it out. Man. Is a Schultz. Saves America.
That's what it is. And then what else do you have going on? Nothing.
Yeah. Stand up or no, I haven't done any actually I have. Yeah.
And weirdly enough, I haven't desired it. Yeah.
I think like my creative juices were fueled by this project that just took so
much time. Yeah, it was okay. And then weirdly enough,
like doing pods, like in hanging around, not my own pod,
but like doing other people's pods,
especially if there's like people in the room,
I start to miss stand up a little bit.
Cause it was almost feels like you're like, yeah,
I'm hearing you tell a funny story.
Like even when you were telling me that story earlier in this podcast, I'm like,
yeah, that'd be a good bit, man. There's like a lot. Cause it sounds,
the story sounds like you're bragging about banging this hot chick. [inaudible]
I'm like, Oh man. At this deal on stage. Yeah. Yeah. But at the same time,
I'm like, I'm not going to perform in like 20 degree weather on a roof. Yeah.
For me, it's not, I don't. Yeah. Like that's not how I want to do it.
People are like calling me, dude. There's a great beat show. And I go, well,
show me a photo. Right. And they're outside.
People are 500 feet away from the stage six feet apart. Right.
I need to hear laughter close. Comfortable.
Yeah. You know, I'm the type of comic that like energy bro,
not energy dat. But also I like to, like, I like to grip people beyond the head.
I meant by like you feed off their energy, you got to connect to them. Yeah.
Yeah. Have you played the Denver comedy works. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
You know how close they are. Right. I just like going what's up bro?
I'm here. You know what I mean? And like, you know what I mean,
40 on somebody or like, you know me doing what I do, you know what I mean?
But it's like, I can't do these vast, you know,
like I'm doing it like a mad max. You know what I mean? It feels spoken word.
Yeah. It feels like a little spoken word.
Like you can go up there and you can like do your misdirection bits and stuff.
Yeah. Or like a joke,
like a story that has a big twist at the end or something and it will work.
But the connectivity is definitely different. And I thrive off that.
Like I want, when I'm with you,
I want to feel your energy when I'm silent and you guys like waiting for the
line, I want to feel that you also do a lot of improv too. I see.
You know what I mean. You know what I mean?
So how do you really riff and all that stuff when they're like 14 feet away?
Yeah. Yeah. What are you wearing? No, really what
it is, come back. That's why I'm not tripping about it.
Like it's going to come back and then we'll be back out there. But like yeah.
And shout out to everybody who's doing the shows like in New York,
like the seller just closed. Then they started to do like these dinner shows.
But the whole time New York comedy club was like shout to Emilio.
They were hustling, dude. They started putting shows on and roofs man.
And in the summer it was fire. Like it was literally like Pete,
you could see across the river.
And like people are on this like lit roof and they were doing like,
they were finding outdoor areas. They just hustled, man.
It was so impressive to see. And um, obviously now it's cold, you know?
And it everything's shut down in New York again. It's annoying,
but I don't know. I, I just, I hope we can get back to it, man. I know.
I'm sorry. I'm so sorry. It's so rude. What happened? You got a call.
You don't know how to turn your own an hour after
the first time it happened. I did it. I'm looking at you,
but my eyes are not full. That's your bad. I have laser off. I know.
I'm so sorry. I just turned it off. Another thing from the two plus.
So we're doing it Tuesday. Oh my gosh.